Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and Welcome back to
Crash Course, Statistics.
One thing that statistics are good for comparing.
You can compare your GPA with the mean or
median GPA, and you can use the standard deviation
to figure out whether the amount of time that
people spend on social media everyday is pretty
similar, or whether people differ a lot.
But both these examples are comparing apples
to apples.
And sometimes we want to compare things that
aren’t exactly the same, or aren’t measured
in the same way.
This is where standardization comes in.
For example some prospective college students
took the SAT, some the ACT and others both.
How can we compare things that aren’t the
same?
It’s like comparing apples to grapefruit.
INTRO
Say there are two students who are applying
for admission to the same college-- one took
only the SAT, and the other only the ACT.
Both tests are trying to measure the same
thing: college readiness.
But they’re different tests, and more importantly,
are measured on different scales; The SAT
is currently out of 1600 points, while the
ACT is out of 36 points.
This makes things tough to compare.
While I can maybe assume that a perfect score
on the SAT and ACT mean similar things--namely
that I’ve found a superstar test taker--it’s
not immediately clear whether a 1200 on the
SAT is better than a 25 on the ACT.
Again, apples to grapefruit.
They’re similar but not quite the same.
The first thing we can do To make these scores
easier to compare is to center both of the
distributions around zero by subtracting the
mean of each respective test from each score.
Now for both adjusted test scores, someone
who got around the mean of either test will
have a score of 0.
So, if you scored a 1000 on the SAT or a 21
on the ACT , your new, adjusted score would
be 0, since those scores are 0 points away
from the means of each test.
Now that both scores are centered around zero,
it’s a little easier to compare them.
Things that are close to zero indicate a score
that was close to the mean, while those far
away from zero indicate scores that were either
a lot higher, or a lot lower than the mean
score for that test.
But our test scores are still on different
scales.
A 10 (above the mean) on the SAT obviously
isn’t the same as at 10 (above the mean)
on the ACT.
The second, and final step that will allow
us to compare these two scores is to take
our already adjusted scores and measure the
distance away from the mean using units of
standard deviation.
We do this by dividing the adjusted scores
by the standard deviation of the respective tests.
This rescales both distributions of scores
so that the standard deviation for both is
now 1 unit.
A re-scaled score, which is called a z-score,
of 1 indicates a point that is 1 standard
deviation higher than the mean, and a z-score
of -1 indicates a point that is 1 standard
deviation lower than the mean.
Now we can better compare two students: Tony
who got a 1200 on the SAT, and Maia who got
a 25 on the ACT.
First we subtract the mean score from each,
and then divide by the standard deviation.
Let’s say those standard deviations are
200 and 4.8 for the SAT and ACT respectively.
So Tony’s score of 1200 minus 1000 divided
by 200 gives a new z-score of 1 (which means
means that it is 1 standard deviations above the mean).
And Maia’s 25 becomes 25 minus 21 divided
by 4.8 giving a new z-score of 0 .83 (which
means that her score is .83 standard deviations
above the mean).
These scores are much more comparable.
It’s easy to see that Tony and Maia’s
z-scores are actually pretty similar, even
though it was hard to tell with their original
scores of 1200 and 25.
Z-scores in general allow us to compare things
that are not on the same scale, as long as
they’re normally distributed.
In fact there’s an entire z-distribution
that allows us to calculate things like percentiles.
Percentiles tell you what percentage of the
population has a score or value that’s lower
than yours.
The median, is the 50th percentile; exactly
half the data is above and below it.
By looking up Tony and Maia’s z-scores in
a standardized z-table, we can see that Both
scored above approximate 80% of their peers
give or take.
You may have seen percentiles at the doctor’s
office when your physician told your parents
that you were at the 83rd percentile for height.
That means that 83% of the population-- and
here we mean kids your age, not all people
ever--have heights that are less than or equal
to yours.
If you look at the whole distribution of heights
and found yours, 83% of the distribution would
be to the left of your height.
Now, technically you can find these percentiles
for any distribution, it involves calculating
the area underneath the curve and figuring
out how much of it is below a certain value.
But that calculation can be tedious, so often
times we convert normal distributions into
standard normal--or z--distributions which
have a mean of 0 and a standard deviation of 1.
Common percentiles have already been calculated
for the z-distribution, you may have seen
a table of them in a statistics textbook.
Say you are competing for a spot at a local
video game convention.
The rules state that you must be in the top
5 percent of scores for your favorite game,
Call of Civic Duty--a jury duty based video
game.
Scores of Call of Civic Duty are normally
distributed with a mean of 2,000 and a standard
deviation of 300.
You get 100 points each day you don’t fall
asleep.
So you set out to find out what score would
put you at the 95th percentile.
Being in the 95th percentile means that you’re
in the top 5 percent of scores since 95% are
below you.
And these are just two different ways of talking
about the same situation.
Looking at our z-score table, we can see that
a z-score of about 1.65 would put you in the
top 5 percent of Call of Civic Duty players.
In fact a z-score of 1.65 corresponds to the
95th percentile of any z-scored distribution.
But we want to turn that back into a Call
of Civic Duty score so that you know just
how high you have to score in order to qualify
for the gaming convention.
We know the process to turn a raw score into
a z-score, so to go the other direction, we
just reverse it.
First, we multiply the z-score by the standard
deviation--300--to get 495.
Then we add the mean score 2,000 to get the
final score to beat: 2,495.
We can also think of percentiles as the probability
that a random score drawn from a z-distribution
will be lower than a given score.
Say, you are at the 90th percentile
for marathon runners.
That means that if we randomly selected a
marathon runner, 90% of the time we’d select
a runner with the same or slower run times than you.
So you’re in the top 10 percent, but does
that mean you’re “extremely” good?
There’s really no clear answer of how good
you have to be or how high a score has to
be in order to be considered “extreme”,
it’s somewhat arbitrary.
You may think the top 10% of marathon runners
are “extreme”, but someone might draw
the line at the top 1%.
In fact, sometimes you can be so extreme that
people might start to think you’re not even
from a certain population z-distribution.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
You’re at the county fair, and stop at a
game booth.
The woman running it says that she has two
piles: one of apples, and one of some type
of mystery object.
She’ll randomly pick an item from one pile.
If you can guess whether she picked an apple
or not, you’ll win a lifetime supply of
funnel cake.
She does kindly tell you that the mean weight
of this type of apple is 200 grams with a
standard deviation of 20 grams.
She grabs an object, weighs it, and yells
out the weight of 270 grams.
You quickly calculate the z-score is 3.5.
You take out your phone and pull up a z-score
table and figure out this object would be
in the top 99.99th percentile, meaning that
it is larger than 99.99 percent of apples.
It’s such a big apple, it’s basically
New York.
If it was an apple, it’s unlikely you’d
get one this big, only 0.001% of the time.
So maybe it’s not an apple.
Before you give your final answer you need
to ask yourself whether you think that’s
rare enough for you to conclude that it’s
probably not an apple, the limit is pretty
arbitrary, but it’s enough here for you
to guess not an apple.
And you swear you see a twinkle in the proprietor’s
eye when she tells you that you’re wrong
and pulls out a very large apple.
As you walk away, you think about how nice
it would have been to know what the mystery
pile was.
If it had been a pile of Bowling Balls, you
probably would have guessed “apple”, even
though it seemed a little heavy since it’s
more likely to have a 270 gram apple than
a 270 gram bowling ball.
But if the other pile were grapefruit, you
might be more inclined to stick with your
original choice of “not an apple”, since
a 270 gram grapefruit is more likely than
a 270 gram apple.
But since you didn’t know, you made the
best choice that you could and you can buy
your own funnel cake.
Thanks Thought Bubble.
Z-scores help us make comparisons.
We can compare a thing to a certain population,
like a particular apple weight to all apple
weights.
And we can compare stuff that’s not naturally
comparable like SAT and ACT scores.
Though we might not calculate actual scores,
the ideas behind z-scores are what make us
feel that the likelihood of being on the same
flight as Chadwick Boseman is way smaller
than the likelihood of hitting 4 red lights
on our way home, even though those things
are very different.
Or maybe we’re trying to compare athletes
from different sports to see who the GOAT is,
no not that kind of goat, Greatest Of All
Time.
Let’s say our top contenders are Lebron
James and Tom Brady.
But who’s the GOAT?
Lebron has a career average of about 27 points
per game, while Brady has an average of 1.92
touchdowns per game between 2000-2017.
While both are impressive, we’re looking
for the greatest.
When we’re picking out our GOAT, we could
compare the two athletes by thinking about
how much higher above the average score each
one has.
But to know which athlete's score is more
impressive we’d need to compare their z-scores.
I haven’t run the math, but off the top
of my head, I’m going with LeBron.
Prove me wrong.
Best analysis wins something that weighs less
than 270 grams.
No other clues.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time.